si el ejército ucraniano ha lanzado una
contra ofensiva para recuperar las zonas
que se encuentran al sur de donde nos
encontramos en la ciudad de heart cova
hay que recordar que esta ciudad de la
segunda más importante del país estamos
en el primer frente de este conflicto
aquí hace unas semanas cayó un misil ha
provocado un gran hoyo de varios metros
y ahora los servicios de emergencia se
encuentran limpiando este lugar del
ataque que se ha producido ahí al lado
una vieja estación de bomberos y también
una escuela donde antes estudiaban aquí
algunos niños en este momento no hay más
no hay mucha población en las calles es
donde nos encontramos justamente y
también esto demuestra como estos
ataques se siguen produciendo en zonas
que no son objetivos estratégicos sino
zonas residenciales como estas